our own investigative reporter sarah
carter authorities telling her that
mexican drug cartels
that they're growing marijuana with
illegal immigrant labor
inside los angeles county now it's
almost hard to believe but you can see
the pictures we have right there on the
screen
yeah that would be marijuana grown
illegally their grow houses is what they
call them
local residents they're terrified here
with more of sarah's report
you know that we have not shown you is
sarah carter
you've decided to speak to me um without
showing your face
yes and part of that is because because
we're
we have a fear they do not but the
residents here do have the fear
and it shouldn't be that way it should
be the other way around you know my son
is here and his children and he's
concerned about it
and he's surrounded where he lives with
these hoop houses and they're becoming
more brazen it's just lawlessness out
here in the desert
feel like it's the wild west yes very
much so it's
it's frightening the way the way it's
headed and if we don't do something
it's just going to get worse not knowing
who the people are
not knowing what they come from and
knowing what they're doing which is an
illegal
illegal activity yeah it's real real
unnerving
what's your worst fear about what could
actually happen to your community or
well i'm assuming that people that live
out here like myself for years
are in the same boat we either will end
up moving or something
worse may happen sources now saying the
military is raising concerns about the
criminal activity observed near
air force sites and republicans they're
fighting back with a california gop
congressman sending a letter to the
attorney general merrick garland
demanding that he
take action here with reaction is one of
those congressmen representative mike
garcia
along with former trump senior adviser
senior uh stephen miller
congressman let's start with you let's
talk about the letter and your
any response yeah sean thanks for having
me very important topic here
we initiated this letter along with my
peers from california
this is a true national security issue
not just for the local citizens as you
saw in the neighborhoods
but we also have a edwards air force
base in my district and they are now
reporting that they're
the personnel are not feeling safe in
their own facilities and they're
actually having to go to places with
escorts
these are international transnational
criminal organizations that are getting
free land
free water growing illegal marijuana
over
several acres there's now thousands of
these illegal grows the problem has
grown exponentially just in the last two
months we've put a bright shiny light on
this but this is exactly why you don't
defund the police
this is exactly why you don't stop
funding border security this is a direct
result of both those
phenomenons and and and unfortunately
it's gotten out of control
uh we're hoping that the attorney
general pays attention with the dea the
fbi as well as the atf and we get all
hands on deck the local sheriff phil
nueva
done a great job in in helping us uh
starting to
get more attention and more resources on
this but we need to support him
and and california which is experiencing
drought and water
shortages for their farmers talking
about 10 million gallons of water daily
according to some estimates
you know it it it's bigger than that too
though stephen this is one part of it
now they're just boldly
they're just you know using and
growing their illegal crops in the u.s
using our electricity using our water
but we can't forget that 90 percent of
all the heroin
in this country crosses that southern
border and the same with fentanyl
and that's killing over 300 300
americans every week
and addiction opioid addiction is way
out of control
what i learned firsthand working with
the heroes of ice and border patrol over
the last four years
is that what happens at the border does
not stay at the border
the criminal organizations that operate
on our southwest border
if they're allowed entry and access into
the country they end up in new york
and california and virginia and
everywhere in between
and you see this time and time again you
have criminal organizations operating
with near
impunity in california because this
administration
dismantled immigration enforcement if we
were in charge right now
we'd be on the phone with ice they'd be
down there making arrests right now
protecting these communities but it's
not happening because joe biden has made
this country a sanctuary country
for criminal illegal immigrants not just
illegal immigrants but
criminal illegal immigrants members of
gangs cartels
drug trafficking networks and they're
going to hurt and kill
innocent americans congressman
if i aided an embedded criminal activity
i think i'd be locked up and put in jail
but maybe i just
i'm one of the few rule followers
because i i realize conservatives are
treated differently
but how is it not aiding and abetting
criminal activity
when we have laws that prevent people
from entering this country illegally
they're not only entering illegally at
in the greatest numbers in 20 years
but they're getting the assistance from
the biden administration
you know 400 000 almost in just the last
two months
they need food water shelter health care
education
who's paying for that congressman yeah
and exactly right sean you're spot on
this is why we need to pay closer to
attend attention to what's happening in
california at all times
where california goes the nation goes
biden's using our state as the blueprint
for his policies
so it's no surprise when he starts
behaving this way
he is now an enabler as at a national
level to one of the largest humanitarian
crisis
this globe has ever seen and it is now
besides our 30 trillion dollars of debt
that you were discussing with maria
the single biggest national security
threat to our nation today
uh it's creeped into my backyard in the
bucolic neighborhoods of palmdale
lancaster
uh and we need to fight back and we are
we're gonna fix this problem
uh but remember this isn't just a
problem in california it's coming to a
neighborhood near you if you're not
paying attention
last word 30 seconds steve miller
i've talked to border agents in recent
days who have described a sophisticated
strategy
on the southwest border where smugglers
sent massive numbers of family units
massive numbers of minors
and then border agents are diverted to
address those numbers of people
and then with the openings that have
been created drugs
contraband weapons cash and criminals
are pouring into the country it's a
sophisticated strategy
border agents know what's happening but
they're being forced
to continue this catch and release
policy on the southwest border that is
making our whole nation less safe
and putting communities in every every
part of this country
in danger and it has to stop all right
congressman thank you steve miller thank
you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else